desde anoche la ciudad de nablús en el
norte de cisjordania ha sido escenario
de violentos enfrentamientos entre
agentes de la autoridad palestina y
militantes armados de hamás y otros
manifestantes lo que por ahora ha
causado la muerte de un hombre de 53
años que jamás ha identificado como uno
de sus milicianos el descontento estalló
luego de que la autoridad nacional
palestina arrestaran a dos miembros del
grupo islamista se trata de musaf
estalle y mohamed ávila a quienes israel
vincula con ataques recientes a
israelíes dei que jamás haya denunciado
que el gobierno de mahmud abás actuó en
palabras textuales bajo las políticas
criminales de ocupación israelí desde
ramala afirmaron tener sus propios
motivos para estas detenciones pero si
se dan justo después de que israel les
haya reprochado a la autoridad palestina
una falta de control en nablús e incluso
en yenín donde el ejército israelí no
cesa sus redadas que para autoridad
palestina son la causa real del
debilitamiento de su gobierno al margen
de israel las protestas en las que se
mezclan milicianos armados
popular son una muestra de la
legitimidad que está perdiendo la
autoridad palestina en cisjordania
acusada por algunos de traicionar a los
palestinos en favor de israel este
escenario ensombrece la reanudación de
los diálogos entre las facciones
palestinas
incluidas hamas y fatá el partido de
mahmud abás que deberían comenzar este 2
de octubre en argelia